what are the different ways uh the
evolution of the exponential scaling of
digital fabrication can evolve so you
said uh yeah self-replicating Nanobots
right this is the the gray goo
fear it's the caricature of a fear but
nevertheless there's interesting just
like you said spam and all these kinds
of things that came with the scaling of
communication and computation what are
the different ways that malevolent
actors will use this technology yeah
well first let me start with a
benevolent story which is
uh uh trash is an analog concept there's
no trash in a forest all the parts get
disassembled and reused trash means
something doesn't have enough
information to tell you how to reuse it
yeah it's as simple as there's no trash
in a Lego room when you assemble Lego
the Lego bricks have enough information
to disassemble them so one of the so as
you go through this Fab one two three
four story one of the implications of
this transition to from printing to
assembling so the real breakthrough
technologically isn't additive versus
subtractive which is the subject of a
lot of attention and hype
um yep 3D printers are useful
um you know we spun off companies like
form Labs led by Max for 3D printing but
in a Fab Lab it's one of maybe 10
machines it's it's used but it's only
part of the machines the real
technological change is when we go from
Printing and cutting to assembling uh
and disassembling but that reduces
inventories of hundreds of thousands of
parts to just having a few parts to make
almost anything it reduces Global Supply
chains to locally sourcing these
building blocks but one of the key
implications is it gets rid of
technological trash
because you can disassemble and reuse
the parts not throw them away and so
initially that's of interest for things
at the end of long Supply chains Like
Satellites on orbit but one of the
things coming is eliminating technical
trash through reuse of the building
blocks so like when you think about 3D
printers you're thinking about solution
and subtraction
when you think about the other options
available to you in that parameter space
as you call it that's going to be
assembly disassembly cutting you said so
the 1952 NC Mill was subtractive your
movement here and 3D printing additive
and there's a couple claims to the
invention of 3D printing that's closer
to what's called net shape which is you
don't have to cut away the material you
don't need you just put material where
you do need it and so that's the 3D
printing Revolution but
there are all sorts of limitations on 3D
printing to the kinds of materials you
can print the kind of functionality you
can print we're just not going to get to
making a
um everything in a cell phone on a
single printer but I do expect to make
everything in a cell phone with an
assembler and so instead of printing and
cutting technologically it's this
transition to assembling and
disassembling it going back to Shannon
and Von Neumann going back to the
ribosome 4 billion years ago
now you come to malevolent
um let me tell you a story about
I was
doing a briefing for the National
Academy of Sciences group that advises
the intelligence communities
and I talked about the kind of research
we do
and at the very end I showed a little
video clip of Valentina in Ghana
um making a local girl making surface
mount Electronics in the Fab Lab and I
showed that to this room full of people
uh one of the members of the
intelligence Community got up livid and
said how dare you waste our time showing
us a young girl in an African village
making service non-electronics we're
looking at we need to know about
disruptive threats to the future of the
United States
and somebody else got up in the room and
yelled at him and you idiot I can't
think of anything more important than
this yeah but for two reasons one reason
was
um because if we rely on like
informational superiority in the
battlefield it means other people could
get access to it but this intelligence
person's point bless him wasn't that it
was
getting at the root causes of conflict
is if this young girl in an African
village could actually Master surface
mount Electronics it changes some of the
most fundamental things about
recruitment for terrorism
um uh impact of economic migration basic
assumptions about an economy it's just
just existential for the future of the
planet but you know we've just lived
through a pandemic
I would love to linger on this because
the possibilities that are positive are
endless yeah but the possibility is a
negative are still nevertheless
extremely important was both positive
and negative what do you do
with a large number of General
assemblers yeah with the Fab Lab you
could roughly make a bio lab then learn
biotechnology now that's terrifying
because making self-reproducing gray goo
that out competes biology I consider
Doom because biology knows everything
I'm describing and is really good at
what it does
um
in
how to grow almost anything you learn
skills in biotechnology that would let
that let you make serious biological
threats and when you combine
some of the Innovations you see with
large language models some of the
Innovations you see with Alpha fold so
applications of AI for Designing
biological systems for uh writing
programs which you can't large language
models increasingly so there seems to be
an interesting dance here of automating
the design stage of complex systems
using Ai and then that's the that's the
bits and you can leap now the
Innovations you're talking about you can
leap from the complex systems in the
digital space to the printing to the
creation to the assembly
at scale
of uh complex systems in the physical
space yeah so something to be scared
about is
a Fab Lab can make a bio lab a bio lab
connect biotechnology somebody could
learn to make a virus that's scary that
that's unlike some of the things I said
I don't worry about that's something I
really worry about that is scary now how
do you deal with that uh
prior threats we dealt with
command and control
so like uh
early color copiers had unique codes and
you could tell which copier made them
eventually you couldn't keep up with
that uh there there was a famous meeting
at asilamar in the early days of
recombinant DNA where that Community
recognized the dangers of what it was
doing and put in place a regime to help
manage it and so that led to the kind of
research management so you know MIT has
an office that supervises research and
it works with the national office that
works if you can identify who's doing it
and where it doesn't work in this world
we're describing so anybody could do
this anywhere and so what we found is
you can't
contain this it's already L you can't
forbid because there isn't command and
control the most useful thing you can do
is provide incentives for transparency
yes so but really the heart of what we
do is you could do this by yourself in a
basement for nefarious reasons or you
could come into a place in the light
where you get help and you get community
and you get resources and there's an
incentive to do it in the open not in
the dark and that might sound naive but
in the sort of places we're working you
know
um again bad people do bad things in
these places already but providing
openness and providing transparency is a
key part of managing these and so it it
transitions from regulating risks as
regulation to to soft power to manage
them so there's so much potential for
good so much capacity for good that Fab
labs and the uh the the ability
um and the tools of creation really
unlock that potential
yeah and I don't say that as sort of
dewey-eyed naive I say that empirically
from just years of seeing how this plays
out in communities I wonder if it's the
early days of personal computers though
before we get spam right